so 60 years how do you think mick jagger
still got it
how do you know how do you explain it i
i gotta tell you so i mean
the funny thing is
whatever
wherever there is excellence people want
to know how did you do it yeah right
what's the secret
not only is mick jagger and i think the
songs that keith richards and and mick
jagger wrote together if you go back and
listen to the lyrics
it's just
incredibly poignant and
i'm just a huge stones fan so but
he works out like a maniac
right and it's
it's that 10 000 hours thing and it's
that
hey maybe i don't feel my best today but
i'm going to get up and do my routine
and work out so that it you know at his
age which you know i mean you can look
at people at different ages
chronologically that are
you know maybe we're both at this age
but i'm a lot older than you are vice
versa
and he just uh
i think it's the combination of raw
talent
and the ability and he's he's very smart
right like he's
understands how to have interaction with
a crowd and hold him in the palm of his
hand and be an entertainer
but then on top of that the reason he
can at this age run around stadiums
and be just as energetic as he puts the
work in
and that's one thing step that i think a
lot of people miss sometimes where they
want that magic trick they want to know
what's the shortcut most of the time the
answer is there's no shortcut yeah you
have to
work hard on the way there and work hard
to stay on top
that's it and sometimes it's not even
like work hard it's just like um it's
like be a professional
which that involves like in his case at
his age with the amount of stuff you
have to do on stage
in the way he does it for two hours you
have this is a professional athlete a
professional athlete
that has to do things that are probably
designed for 20 year olds and 30 year
olds has to do it in an older age which
means like what do you have to do well
you have to probably he probably has
like a whole physical routine he has to
do diet the whole thing and it's hard
look
if you want to do great things you
probably have to do hard things yeah to
get there
i'm not going to make you pick just
stick on the stones for one more minute
um
but what are some
great
rolling stones songs that were
impactful to you lyrically musically
maybe something uh
you like playing uh like air guitar or
uh i don't know
probably my favorites i love sympathy
for the devil yeah uh it's a very
i don't know sort of faustian i i love
the lyrics i love the how the almost a
voodoo beat just kind of builds
throughout the song
um that's that's always been one of my
favorites so in that song he never
mentions devil does he no wait sorry uh
uh
like you know my name yeah there's
there's like a flirtation going around
in the in the lyrics it's kind of
interesting yeah it's it's here's all
the trouble i've caused along the way
with you humans and i i just think it's
really really great and musically builds
really nicely yeah it's it's it's like
both fun and dark it it's it's cool it's
a
uh
it's it's there's a playful nature to it
it's uh that that's very stones like the
only they can pull it off because it's
like playful but it's also like dark and
dangerous dangerous dangerous yeah yeah
and give me shelter in the shelter it's
just
you know and um to this day when i
listen to the studio version
and mary clayton just comes on and sings
that
epic
iconic part
and uh there's a documentary that was
done
about uh backup singers
phenomenal and it tells the story of
that moment in that song with mary
clayton and it's just uh
her voice and and the way it unfolded
they got her out of bed at like 10
o'clock at night in la and she's like
the rolling stones what
and went in and just killed it
and um i can't sing at all i'm by
ordinance not a lot around a microphone
so i'm always in awe when someone
can sing like that
um
but uh you know those are those are some
of my uh my favorite rolling stone songs
and
painted blacks awesome i mean i could go
on yeah painted black is great again a
song that builds is badass i mean it
defines a whole generation
you